normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government as
we're talking about living in a
simulation and the AI I present to you
this an urgent Manhunt is underway in
the New Jersey town of heleta for a
suspect in connection to the January 6th
Capital attack Gregory Yetman evaded
arrest and fled into the woods near his
home uh see ABC has the latest on the
scene they actually interviewed his
neighbor whose name name is
stazzy bro welcome okay like like really
quick the big breaking news is a j sixer
is currently on the Run they're using
apc's dogs they're hunting him down but
the neighbor's name is stazzy and
everyone's just kind of sitting back
being like yo we're in a simulation even
better segue from the last topic is that
it's hell meta that's the future when
we're all in the metaverse I'm thinking
that that is hell and that is meta wow
dude that's crazy it's a it's a
simulation L meta this problem the
problem with the simulation is it's the
the writers of the simulation are so bad
right like they're on strike or
something and and it's so on the nose
it's so on the nose Meta Meta will be
hell dude we should copyright that right
now that's amazing so uh com I mean so
this is the big story you know I don't
want to get all sci-fi and creepy and
crazy with it this is a guy another
Ginger look at that they're coming after
feel persecuted yeah so so apparently
the story is that he had already spoken
with the FBI and they cleared him and
then something happened with USA Today
where they revealed more information
about him and then the feds went to go
serve an arrest warrant and he ran into
the woods guy who did something three
years ago is now a breaking news Manhunt
this makes no sense to me yo and they're
shutting schools down
AEL shelter shelter and place order W
well hold on we don't know this guy was
nonviolent I don't want to say that
right there were people there who were
Absol absolutely violent and I don't
know if they have photos of of what he
was doing or whatever while he was there
but maybe he was this guy was in the
National naal guard at the time of j6 so
that's kind of crazy he brought a
Humvees do you see that what to j6 yeah
there's a picture of it he must have
done
it wow no I think that's do you know him
from the group message you text him and
ask him to run through the woods
here no I mean I just like maybe he was
violent but at the same time it is crazy
to me that they are still arresting
people in connection to January 6th in
perpetuity forever and ever the end like
I'm skeptical that he is if he was such
a dangerous person that they would have
let it go this long I I'm sorry I I just
got to say this like there was something
that happened a couple years ago related
to Trump that was so insane like I was
it I'm like we're in a simulation like
how could this possibly be I can't
remember exactly what happened we talked
about in the show and everyone was
laughing like this is nuts now we're
literally talking about how weird all of
this is and we have a j6 are fleeing
into the woods whose neighbor's last
name is stazzy in the town of Hell meta
look this is what I'm saying about post
reality post reality is totality the
totality of events occurring both
digital and physical as a simulation
Burns but the simulation is not the
zeros and ones type of simulation I
believe the simulation is being
engineered by like corporate press and
government no we're in the final Seasons
like you know the first few seasons of
Simpsons were just awesome like the
first nine and then after that it's just
been like a downward spiral of like
they're not going to let the show end
all the good writers left right I I
think this is where we're at and what
we're getting is they're just they have
no creativity anymore so they're like
it's a guy whose neighbor is the stazzy
or something well we can't do that so
her name is stazzy oh that's good I like
that do that it's like an SNL sketch
know it's ridiculous or maybe they're
exhibitionists and they just want to be
seen I don't know man like this is crazy
stuff we say simulation but the reality
is I'm sure a lot of Christians are just
like this is God's Universe like you're
starting to see it you know what I mean
well that's how I feel I think we're in
base reality God's reality and that
people are engineering this false
reality on top of it not to say that
this guy running around is but the way
these things are like hell met
or or you know stazzy and any other
thing that's been happening the past
year just seems so fake like they're
trying to make us buy into this
aggressively unreal reality not to say
this isn't happening there's a lot of
horrible things happening in the world
it'd be funny if we're actually already
in the pods eating the bugs and they're
just like playing and toying with us as
we're strapped in and we're just like
what this is life we're in base reality
and then pans out to base reality we're
already in the PT with tubes in our
throats we're just extras in a Black
Mirror episode don't know it yeah that
was another another idea I had a while
back of like what if what if why here's
my argument for why we are all
NPCs when the NPCs don't know that
they're NPCs and the people who are
playing the game know they're playing
the game so if you aren't aware that
you're an external you you're outside
system playing the game then you're the
NPC and we're sitting here talking and
we're basically three it's three dog
right that was the guy from uh uh uh uh
fallout the radio host so when you're
playing Fallout it's a post-apocalyptic
Wasteland you turn the radio on and he's
talking right and that's it that's
basically you're the player you're
playing the game and we're the
background noise to facilitate your your
our voices in a wasteland yeah like I I
would have to assume that like this is
this is Trump's game you know Trump is
the Trump is like some 15-year-old
playing the video game of like it's
called like Earth right and he's he's
that's his character and he's playing
and he's like you know he's it's is
nearing the the end of the game or
whatever and we're just ancel characters
I like to think not but it does feel
like that sometimes for sure that
doesn't matter if it does or doesn't I
guess your life is your life would it
change how you act that's always my
question it wouldn't for me I would
still act with the moral code I Believe
In You know despite yeah you'd go crazy
I do what I want and you wouldn't know
if you weren't doing what you want
because apparently we're all in the pods
anyway I'm just kidding so do this guy
have charges brought against him serving
an arest an arrest warrant his last his
last name is yet man what this is what
I'm seeing from they caught him yet they
haven't caught they haven't caught him
yet man the New York Times says that he
was uh he had been interviewed by the
FBI for his participation in the and
that he was believed to have uh fired a
large canister of Pepper Sprite at
protesters and the police this guy was
on no one's side it's just you with a
haircut
my you all know each other right from
the ginger j6 sub subreddit what if the
aliens are actually just like uh game
moderators and the reason they can defy
physics is because their vehicles are
outside of the game for the for the
purpose of facilitating the simulation
right we can't see them the way the ants
aren't perceiving us I like yo this I I
I'm just I'm flabbergast at reading the
story because it looks like it's like
when a when a game writer has his kid
write up a a quest you know it's a guy
who who's working for World of Warcraft
has his 11-year-old son write up a quest
for him they'll put in the game and
he'll put it in because it's funny and
he can if if when I was a uh professor
of creative writing let's say and a
student came to me with a like this I
would say maybe this is like unless it's
a satire maybe this is all to on the
nose cuz every name is ridiculous hell
meta like we're just we're not reaching
that far yet man and like come on this
is like a vonet rather you know maybe
they're using vonet stories I don't know
you know I just found out recently just
a little side note on the post- reality
stuff that vag's brother invented
seeding clouds w wow dude silver ey died
seaing that was him yeah yeah what a fun
family yeah just just all kinds of stuff
for the simulation people out there
maybe it's like a Truman Show mhm you
know I wonder who Truman would
be well maybe it's Trump or maybe it's
just Shi you know from from all of us
Trum in heleta and that's how they're
keeping him inside because they're like
hey there's a man Hound to go outside
right now we got to change the sets real
quick to charge little birds everyone go
inside for Co lock was it'd be funny if
Trump is like like Earth as a Truman
Show we're we're all ancillary
characters it don't matter but the
aliens watch Trump all day and they're
like they love him I mean who doesn't
love watching Trump he's an entertaining
and there's several seasons in so it's
getting really off the rails they don't
know to do but there is real world data
to support this theory in terms of uh
Donald Trump's Uncle having the Tesla
stuff either Trump is a time traveler or
he or or he knows the aliens wait so is
is yay just like a Side Story is it like
a different he was like a fun
character is Roy right like okay they
they introduce a random character to
boost the ratings and then he's gone a
season later true oh I was thinking like
all the dimensions kind of merged in the
past few years and yay is another
protagonist From Another Dimension like
a
cross and Trump did meet up for a bit
but they're like we're too crazy to do
this together Marvel and DC kind of met
yeah I would say cone is close to The
Truman Show though because Truman did
break somewhere towards the end of the
show it's Kanye you know what I think is
funny I was watching the I was watching
clips from The Truman Show because
there's a meme where it's
uh he's Truman is arguing with his wife
and then she's like whatever COC ex yeah
and he's like who are you talking to but
that wouldn't be weird him because she
would have been doing that his whole
life yeah it would have been a normal
social thing to be like look at product
it's a great product you'd be like yep
that's what people do and we're all used
to it now because of influencer culture
he'd be doing the same thing hey I'm
just on my Instagram stories like
putting my kids to bed and I thought I'd
tell you about this thing just randomly
because I'm definitely getting sponsored
to do it I'm sorry I got to do it like
as much as I love the daily wire guys
and I think they're doing such great
work I just got to point out one thing I
could never do is because if you've
watched their shows you know exactly
what they do they'll say something like
I got to tell you when I learned about
how great VI ramaswami did at that
debate I was so happy to hear it as
happy as I was to try spin drift an
excellent drink where and I'm just like
I know it's seamless and it's probably
the better way to do an ad read but I
just I could never do that yeah yeah
it's uh kind of like how I feel on on X
these days when I see something about
for instance it was it was on Scott
Adams uh page and it was about the 3D
printed suicide pods with an ad right
below it for let's say a a device for
pleasure for women uh and I was just
like that is so and it's and it was like
a lady waving goodbye in the Pod smiling
next to to this ad saying like double
the pleasure it's like this is just a
horrible I got I got to give a shout out
to Michael nolles I guess he sold out of
like four months worth of cigars yeah
wow yeah and I'm like well now I got to
buy I don't smoke but like got to
support the parallel economy man we've
got Jeremy soap downstairs what is is
that a thing I is there soap now yeah
there was I saw that soap and deodorant
and I'm like what I didn't know that
existed I was just waiting for him with
like dark chocolate but instead he was
like on to the next product give it time
see like there's going to be two
realities in 5050 years there's going to
be the people who live in the pods and E
the bugs outside you're going to go to
Jeremy's which is like you go inside
it's a superstore warehouse that has
every product sign up for Jeremy's
membership and they got everything they
got beef they got Pork yeah it's
basically Costco but it'll be called
Jeremy yeah we'll get there I would do
ad reads for fun products like not real
ones like ejection seats and helicopters
like
a Oh what a beautiful image but it is
interesting this idea that like people
people are trying to read uh meaning or
value like I think people feel so lost
in everything that's happening they're
trying to find Clues like this idea that
it's heleta like is this the sign are we
looking for something and I think that
is again this craving for direction in
life that people just don't have thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 P.M and become a
member over at
timcast.net Ive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time